أوه
[تصفيق]
أن استمالة كل تلك الذراع التي تضخ
متسابقًا يُدعى هنري كان فائزًا في "
السعر صحيح"، لكنه لم يكن
يعلم الثمن الإضافي الذي سيدفعه مقابل
حماسه، نعم
[تصفيق]
إحدى موجات الذراع المنتصرة هذه
خلعت كتف هنري.  عندما حان
الوقت لتدوير العجلة، كان على زوجته أليس
أن تفعل ذلك نيابة عنه كما تم نشر العرض
على Instagram، لقد فاز برحلة إلى هاواي وغرفة
الطوارئ
لا تؤذي نفسك ولكن
المتسابقين الآخرين قد أذوا أنفسهم في
السعر صحيح
أصيبت جودي  كاحلها وقامت برحلة
إلى المستشفى ولكن ليس قبل الانتهاء من
العرض على عكازين والعودة عندما كان بوب
باركر هو المضيف هيا الآن، لم
ينزل سكوت للتو، لقد سقط من الألم،
عربة المحطة الجديدة
[تصفيق]
أصيبت في ركبته  لقد كان الأمر سيئًا بما فيه الكفاية لأنه تم
تقديمه
مرتين في حلقة واحدة
من هذا البرنامج،
لا أحد آمن بالتأكيد ليس
المذيع
أوه لذا، والمضيف درو كاري في
خطر دائم من أن يتم احتضانه حتى الموت
على الأقل لم يفقدوا أي
عرض للمصابيح الكهربائية  يجب أن تعيد التفكير في جوائز
الإقامة لمدة سبع ليالٍ في المستشفى، حيث
تجعل عربة المحطة الجديدة أن سيارة الإسعاف
التي تركب جزازة العشب أفضل من
الكرسي المتحرك، ولكن ربما يكون السعر
مناسبًا لعرض الألعاب التأمين
CNN New York